[Music]
I don't even notice art except to say
thank you I'm just a little overwhelmed
by how many of you watched and
subscribed and left really thoughtful
comments it was actually my first time
doing something like that so I was a
little nervous and you guys are amazing
I think I'm excited to put more videos
out so that's exactly what I want to do
right now I want to answer some
questions that you guys had and by the
way there were a lot of really great
questions and comments um great topics
for videos moving forward but the
biggest three that I kept saying over
and over again where Dre's a bathroom
when I have to go number two where do I
shower and how do I do my laundry so
let's dive in okay so there's my toilet
we have this I don't know what you'd
call it but you have to pump it ten
times roughly in order to create some
pressure so that you can flush well uh
and then you pull open this lever down
here and that empties the toilet just
like that and you feel the water over
here oh wow I did not expect that to
happen I guess it's because I'm kind of
up in the high country I have to go
number one I'm golden I'm totally fine
all I have to do is empty that thing
when it gets full which for me on
average is already like six to seven
days and it's easy to empty I'm not
going to show you how I do it today
because I have to go find a location and
it's a little time consuming but it's
not that time-consuming I'm just being
lazy I'll show you another day today I
want to talk about number two okay so
it's the morning I just had my cup of
coffee I gotta go the bathroom what do I
do um alright so if I'm in a city this
is a lot easier
typically since I'm self-contained and I
like to work in Maidan a lot i'll let's
go find like a public park and they have
bathrooms there they usually open around
6:00 a.m. some a little later or
whatever but there's so many options if
you're in a city grocery stores a lot of
them are open 24 hours or they open
early I
to eat vegetables ate a ton of produce I
shop lick three to four times a week not
even kidding which might sound crazy but
when you live on the road you're
constantly going past grocery stores so
it's not really a big deal you're always
you never like at home and you have to
make a special trip you're just cruising
by so grocery stores always have
bathrooms and so that's that's a great
option I also really love libraries
they're quiet there are no distractions
and coffee shops if I need like strong
Wi-Fi that's usually my go-to
it's also great because you are
patronizing a local coffee shop away
from a city it's a little more
challenging but I tend to hang out
around national park state parks so in
that case I can just use a bathroom
within the park or I can use pet toilets
sometimes I park outside of friends
houses and I can use their bathrooms in
the morning shout-out to my friends you
guys are awesome the number one place
that I go is the gym so that touches on
the second thing which is where do I
take a shower I personally use Anytime
Fitness and this is after trying a few
different trims I tried 24-hour Fitness
Planet Fitness
they're both great but I decided
obviously not to chew those for
different reasons it's 24-hour access
you just have a key fob so you don't
have to check in or go during hours or
whatever sometimes there they have
complimentary shampoo component
conditioner towel service at some of the
locations they're just really well
maintained they're often not too busy
which is really great unlike some of the
other bigger gyms and the locations they
tend to have them dotted all throughout
the West Coast but rather than be super
concentrated in large cities they're
also on the outskirts so there are a lot
more options when you're staying on BLM
land or national forests or heading into
a state park when I go to the gym I just
grab my gym bag this is a microfiber
towel that dries really quickly my
shampoo conditioner hair dryer what I
like to do is if I'm not going straight
to a coffee shop to do work then I try
to go to the gym every morning depending
on where I am so I'll work out and then
I'll do my business shower and voila
another option for showers is
truck stops I've never actually used one
but I've seen them when I stopped and I
have friends that use them and I think
they range from like seven to nine
dollars or something I'm not too
expensive they're a little more
expensive than I want to pay I just use
the gym but that's always an option
friends houses campgrounds are really
reliable usually you just pay like a day
you Spee which could be as little as
five dollars other really great options
are aquatic centers so I've used those
in various places they're usually three
to five dollars to just going to use the
shower for the day if I'm gonna mean a
place for a long time like Moab is a
great example I like to post up there
for three to four weeks sometimes and
they have an aquatic center there so I
just buy a monthly membership and I go
to the gym every day I shower use the
bathroom I can fill my water it's it's
great and I think it was like $40 for
the whole month oh where do I do laundry
guys laundry is super simple I just go
to a laundromat so whenever I'm passing
through a town or city I just do my
laundry I only do my laundry every two
to three weeks and depending on where
you are you know prices vary but it's
typically seven dollars or less
sometimes for the washing and the dry I
also use friends houses sometimes if
they'll let me I should also mention
that as a photographer I'm being sent on
trips pretty often with the brands that
I work with and also to shoot for
tourism boards so when I do that I get I
flown somewhere and I stay in hotels and
or it's locally I just drive and then
I'm put up in hotels so that kind of
breaks up living on the road all the
time I live in this van 24/7 with the
exception of those work trips and
sometimes I'll house it for friends or
I'll just stay with friends all the
things that I talked about the shower
the laundry the toilet those are legit
concerns I was freaked out about them
before I moved into my SUV and it's it
took a little bit of adjusting but once
you kind of get over that hump of just
trying to come to terms with the fact
that you can't go sit on your toilet for
two hours in your own house if you want
to which
any of you do but you can't go take a
shower in your own home whenever you
want yeah those are drawbacks for sure
like their drawbacks but I think at the
end of the day for me at least it's well
worth like the the pros far outweigh the
cons I mean I get to wake up wherever I
want I get to go wherever I want and I
always have my house and my office with
me and yeah that's kind of hard to beat
for me like it's not for everyone but I
just wanted to make that clear if that's
holding you back look into it like
there's so many different options that
you can just get creative with it so
guys I really hope that was helpful um
again I am trying really hard to answer
all of your questions I have like a lot
of commercial work going on right now
and some trips coming up but eventually
I would love to get in the habit of
posting every week so we'll see thank
you for being patient with me and yeah I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
you